das gesicht eines menschen verrät und
seine gefühle eine universelle sprache
die jeder versteht
doch es gibt menschen denen die
fähigkeit fehlt die emotionen in der
mimik ihr gegenüber zu leeren
menschen mit autismus wie rainer können
in den gesichtern ihrer mitmenschen
nicht erkennen
dadurch haben die schwierigkeiten auf
andere emotional zu reagieren
sie fühlen sich ausgegrenzt und einsam
wissenschaftler an der humboldt
universität in berlin erforschen wie man
menschen beibringen kann gefühle richtig
zu deuten
dieser welt so beck entwickelt mit ihrem
team methoden mit denen autisten darf es
eigentlich intuitiv geschehen soll
erlernen können perfekt von menschen mit
autismus kindern sind unterwegs um zu
helfen in der welt zurecht zu kommen
ich glaube dass ein ganz wesentlicher
aspekt mit einer menschen auf zu kommen
und das ist so wichtig nicht nur für
unsere zu erleben auch für unser
berufsleben praktisch alles in seinem
leben
ich glaube dass ein ganz wesentlicher
aspekt ist dass sie anderen menschen
lesen können
[Musik]
isabell czech team hat eine software
entwickelt die autistischen menschen
ermöglicht das erkennen von emotionen
dafür haben schauspieler mehr als 40
gefühle - zum ausdruck gebracht wie
sehen wir aus wenn wir gerührt
frustriert oder einfach glücklich sind
diese kleinsten veränderungen in der
mimik in tausenden von ausdrücken müssen
autisten mühsam erlernen
eine aufgabe besteht darin die ausdrücke
von augen und mund richtig zusammen zu
fügen
autisten sollen verstehen welche
einzelnen kleinen bewegungen welchem
gefühlszustand entsprechen in früheren
studien die wir gemacht haben haben
herausgefunden dass menschen mit oft
weniger auf die augen schauen denn leute
die viele ausdrucken und in die augen
aber ganz besonders wichtig wenn wir
gefühle lesen wollen die häufig am
ausdrucksstärksten sind
[Musik]
deshalb zeigen die wissenschaftler den
autisten wohin sie schauen wollen nur
drei stunden training pro woche
verbessern das lesen von gesichtern
isabell werth hat herausgefunden dass
sich diese fähigkeit in einer messbaren
aktivierung des gehirns widerspiegelt
von welcher region dafür entscheiden
will
das gehirn zu stimulieren geht am besten
im kindesalter dass vorgaben von simone
kirchen soll autistischen kindern die
soziale interaktion erleichtern
den autisten verfügen genau wie jeder
andere über gefühle wie können sie nur
nicht passend ausdrücken
lutz hat das sogenannte asperger syndrom
eine spezielle entwicklungsstörung
innerhalb des autismus
lutz geht auf eine normale schule wird
überdurchschnittlich intelligent auf der
kontakt mit anderen kindern fällt ihm
schwer im unterricht macht er richtig
gut mit erhard sport fahren da klappte
es ganz toll
das problem die schwierigkeiten sind
dann die pausen mit weißem pfeffer
machen soll das vor der tat es dann dass
er sich die käuferin war vereinzelt zu
stänkern zu schuften einfach um auf sich
aufmerksam zu machen zu sagen hey ich
will mit euch reden aber erkranken dann
neue trainingsprogramm wird heute zum
ersten mal getestet wird es auf anhieb
die gefühle der schauspieler deuten und
benennen können
im programm für erwachsene geht es darum
die verschiedenen gefühls ausdrücke beim
gegenüber zu erkennen
kinder sollen zudem lernen adäquat auf
die emotionen ihrer mitmenschen zu
reagieren
lutz macht ein solches training schon
seit jahren und hat in dieser zeit
erhebliche fortschritte gemacht es war
nicht einfach mit witz und da wird man
dann auch mal in tränen aus und da hat
er gelacht da hat es gefreut das fand
ich total aufnimmt und heute ist es so
wenn ich jetzt mit fähnchen haare dann
kommt er unseren taschentuch erfolg
nicht immer noch ein bisschen aber er
weiß es ist was trauriges und er weiß
wir reagieren muss damit sie die
gesichter erkennen und andere menschen
emotional einschätzen können autistische
menschen aber permanent üben
[Musik]